[Music]
they're always in my state like
everywhere I go have a studio know that
whether it's the house or whether it's
my office there's always the studio and
my son loves the drum my daughter does
too but she's more like on the piano
itself
Nick Cannon gushing over his twins
musical skills to et and sounds like son
maracas and might have a family holiday
song ready to go I have a pitch for you
all right
I think that we need a new holiday song
you Mariah the kids all on one child
love it I love the funniest a Oh another
goes to say this but my son maybe like
two years ago he wrote a song he was
turning five and he wrote a Christmas
song and I was really excited and I'll
tell you totally tomorrow I'm like oh I
he told me he wrote a Christmas song
she's like yeah have you heard it and I
was like no I was like next thing he's
like telling the sing it for you name it
this is my son's Christmas song no joke
he goes I saw your boobies on Christmas
Eve they were so beautiful
I didn't wanna leave it's my boy right
my son wrote that all by himself when
you're turning five
it was amazing we need to release that
this is the best Christmas song I ever
heard in my life
all right so now we need to get you guys
in the studio that's all yes we need
some legs just off to rock Mariah's
gonna kill me that I told you
you
[Music]